ich berichte ja für die cdu und da haben
sich gestern und heute noch alle
wahnsinnig gefreut weil frau merkel sie
wieder lieb hat frau merkel hat auf
einer pressekonferenz gesagt ich bin
nicht olaf scholz und das hat in der
union jubelstürme ausgelöst war olaf
scholz behauptet ja seit wochen er wäre
die neue angela merkel posiert mit der
raute und es schlich sich der versagt
ein dass sie das selber auch so sieht
und jetzt hat sie gesagt er ist doch
nicht ganz wie ich sie hat zwar nur den
einen punkt gemacht ich habe vorher
gesagt dass ich nicht mit der linken
koalieren aber alle in der cdu sind
glücklich und da darf man sich die haben
sie auch sonst gerade nicht so leicht
ein bisschen mit freuen und deshalb
werde ich jetzt auch nicht erzählen dass
frau merkel schon mal im kanzleramt
dafür gesorgt hat dass bodo ramelow ein
ministerpräsident der linkspartei wieder
in sein amt eingesetzt wird in einem
koalitionsausschuss das war schweigen
wir können das nicht hier das ist sagen
wir das gehört das ist hier richtig
sagen und genau deswegen muss das glaube
ich hier auf dem tisch man hat jetzt
nicht diese deutlichen worte der
bundestrainer schon wieder so genau auf
möglicherweise als auch cdu chefin war
gerade richtung linkspartei deutlich
öfter gewünscht ganz klar vielleicht
auch zu dem ein oder anderen
parteifreund ich kenne mich an daniel
günther der ich glaube es war im sommer
zwei 18 jahre schon davon fabulierte
dass die cdu in thüringen
möglicherweise öffnen müsste er gab ein
doppel 1 verbindung ist mit der liga
dann gab es das danach jagte wien
erfolgreich für richtig erachtet das
doppel interview für bodo ramelow gut
also machten wir müssen gucken ich
glaube weiterhin noch dass armin laschet
die trendwende noch hinbekommt
möglicherweise auf der hilfe der
kanzlerin oder auch nicht aber die große
frage die ich habe an sie frau suding
ist müsste die fdp nicht jetzt eine
zweitstimmenkampagne eigentlich für die
union fahren es kann doch christian
lindner gut sie scheinen aus dem
bundeshaus sowas kann auch christian
lindner und ihrem parteifreund
eigentlich nicht egal sein ob sie nun
armin laschet zum kanzler mit wild oder
olaf scholz also die zweitstimmen
brauchen wir und dann sind sie auch am
besten aufgehoben aber das heißt jetzt
werden wir natürlich auch dafür werben
dass die zweitstimme fdp aber es ist
okay dass ich fair nach nach jahrzehnten
zweitstimmen kampagne der union für die
fdp jetzt die zweitstimmenkampagne der
fdp für die in not befinden wie er so
gut wie ich dass das wäre wahlkampf da
keine stimmen zu verschenken haben das
hat niemand und das ist ja auch
vollkommen richtig dass da jeder für
sich selber kämpfen dass wir natürlich
auch toll und wichtig ist für mich
einfach nur das ist eine starke fdp gibt
die in einer konstellation und da gibt
es ja mehrere denkbare wenn man sich die
aktuellen umfragen anguckt mitregiert
stark mitregiert da viel durchsetzen
kann und das ist egal der kanzler schulz
oder kanzler lasche das wäre jetzt der
fdp begannen sich die legal ist ist gar
nichts aber wenn man sich die
parteiprogramme auf nebeneinander legt
dann ist natürlich mehr schnittmenge zur
union da das ist glaube ich unbestritten
und
insgesamt nett aber wir müssen gucken
was ist am ende rechnerisch möglich dann
wird man sprechen und innerhalb des
demokratischen spektrums sollte man auch
koalitionsfähig sein dazu gehören für
mich auf gar keinen fall die fdp dazu
könnte mich auch nicht die linken und
nicht erst seitdem sie letzte woche sich
durch die nicht zustimmung zum
evakuierungs mandat komplett ins aus
geschossen haben aber natürlich klar
gibt es mehr übereinstimmung mit der
union und dann werden wir mal sehen was
mir passt warum hängt denn olaf scholz
du kennst die spd ja nun auch sehr gut
warum hält denn olaf scholz dann diese
flanke ein noch offen warum sagt er
nicht ganz klar so wie es gerade gesagt
hat es gibt eine brandmauer zu fd von
allen demokratischen parteien und es
muss doch eigentlich auch die
brandmauern nicht eigentlich ist muss
doch auch die brandmauer zur linkspartei
geben ja es gibt da im
parteitagsbeschluss der im grunde diese
mögliche zusammenarbeit offen hält und
zudem würde auch nicht widersprechen ich
denke er versucht das ja
verklausuliert deutlich zu machen wenn
er sagt wir werden nicht koalieren mit
einer partei die gegen die nato bald und
die nato verbleib ist das ist ja durch
die blume gesprochen nicht erinnere aber
er hat eine offene flanke damit das ist
klar es gibt auch die theorie dass er
damit die linkspartei stimmen einfahren
will da habe ich meine zweifel ob das
wirklich eine taktik ist mit seiner
strategie kommt die wir zu mir als
dorthin da habt ihr mehr
von von spd-politikern er richtung union
er wird sagen die brandmauer zu auf
demos stehen die muss stehen die muss
stehen alles spd-politiker von olaf
scholz über lars klingbeil haben die
union gemacht und gesagt das muss stehen
afd dürfte nicht machen und umgekehrt
zur linkspartei your strategische option
anschließend mit der nato also alles
untersucht kam ja gleich insofern ist es
so ich bin auch kein fan von einer
zusammenarbeit mit der sogenannten
linkspartei das war ist eine partei die
sicherlich große defizite hat weiterhin
auch insofern sehe ich da auch gar nicht
den punkt nur ist es klar dass olaf
scholz damit eine strategische lücke
lässt und jeder kann hier aus welchen
gründen auch immer da reinstecken und
das muss erschließen oder sagte ich
lasse das weiterlaufen interessiert
sowieso kein witzigerweise gab es ja
eine befragung von der forschungsgruppe
wahlen vor einer woche gefragt hat
welche koalition wünschen sich die
deutschen am liebsten und tatsächlich
das
g37 das war der größte wert haben gesagt
wir wünschen sich eine ampel mit seiner
ampel also spd grüne und fdp oder in
einer anderen reihenfolge dann haben sie
gesagt das zweite eine rot rot grüne
regierung ganz abgeschlagen war grün rot
rot aber rot-rot-grün war mit diesen 37
prozent bei der forschungsgruppe wahlen
die ja bekanntlich jetzt kein
unterstützer ist so viel man weiß eben
eines solchen modells
auf nummer 1b und das hat mich sehr
überrascht zeigt vielleicht dass das
thema doch nicht so greift wie viele
denken naja alexander bei ihrem thema
was sie auch heute mitgebracht haben hat
denn jetzt frau merkel laschet was
gebracht ihre aussagen also es ist jetzt
gut im wahlkampf dass frau merkel sich
positionieren da hatte mir vorgenommen
ihn nicht den spaß zu verderben aber ich
halte es nicht durch sie hat das
absolute minimum getan also die in der
union die waren so kommen musste wenn
sie das jetzt gestern nicht gesagt hätte
hätten die sie öffentlich ermahnt das
wollte frau merkel nicht aus der
pressekonferenz gefragt worden ansonsten
sage ja ich bin wie olaf scholz wäre
aber sie hat das absolute minimum
geliefert und dasselbe hat sich aber im
cdu wahlkampfauftakt das sollte ja die
große live-show werden und dann gab es
noch jede von merkel aber die war gar
nicht verlasse das war eine rede meine
bilanz was habe ich alles richtig
gemacht und gibt jetzt mehr elektroautos
als früher und afghanistan hinterher ist
man immer schlauer
dann hat sich das über laschet gesagt
und hat gesagt für dich steht das c im
parteinamen das nimmst du richtig ernst
und für die steht die würde des menschen
im mittelpunkt seines schaffens und das
ist stimmt auch aber andererseits wir
wählen ja nicht den
pfarrgemeinderatsvorsitzenden also dass
laschet ein guter christenmensch ist
nimmt ihm jeder ab aber er steht ja
gegen olaf scholz wo die leute sagen wir
da war ja finanzminister und also da
hätte man sich ja auch noch mehr im
phase für herner schritt vorstellen es
war ein hartes fällt mit weniger kann
man über einen spitzenkandidaten
eigentlich gar nicht sagen das ist nicht
so aufgenommen worden die sie es gerade
dargestellt haben jeder war da eher
zurückhaltend aber so habe ich es auch
empfunden japan denken sie denken auch
das war kein gutes statement verlassen
das hätte man sich auch sparen können
das ist natürlich zeigt natürlich wenn
man wenn man schon was sagt und gesagt
das ist das ja auch eine aussage und
keine gute idee denn die kanzlerin
eigentlich die cdu
ich kann ihr weder hinter die stirn
hinter die wahl gerne gucken aber ich
glaube dass man als ernsthafter zu
wenden frau merkel tut was nutzt jetzt
nehmen wir mal an armin laschet gewinnt
das noch dann kann sie sagen nachdem cdu
kanzlerin ist ein cdu kanzler gewählt
worden das gab es noch nie nehmen wir an
es gewinnchance dann kann sie sagen der
mann der seit monaten erzählt er möchte
meine politik fortsetzen ist gewählt
worden jetzt nehmen wir an frau berbalk
mit gewählt worden sagt sie ich war die
erste frau und das volk noch eine frau
also egal wer gewinnt frau merkel
gewinnt immer meine meinung ist trotzdem
ein anderes trotzdem sie ist ja schon
nicht aus freien stücken gegangen das
wollte sie einst hat er immer gesagt sie
wollten selbst bestimmt aus dem
anschalten wir wissen ganz genau auch
dass sie den parteivorsitz niedergelegt
hat das hat sie nicht aus freien stücken
gemacht da standen einfach zu schlechte
umfragewerte vorhergesagt war ihr immer
schon nicht so da ist es ja ein
machtverfall der dann das wort man
verfall hier am tisch was soll ich dazu
sagen
ist ja dann auch ganz klar deutlich
geworden es ist dadurch für eine
bundeskanzlerin die aus dem amt scheiden
deswegen glaube ich schon hat sie das
bewusst gemacht
dann schon eine schmach zu sehen nach 16
jahren regierung habe ich es nicht
geschafft jemanden aus der partei die
zitat mir nahe steht oder wer ich
nahestehen zitat ende ins kanzleramt zu
bringen bewegung funktioniert politik
dass sich jeder und dann stehe ich dann
steht in den geschichtsbüchern am ende
merkel booms und dann hat sie es auch
noch dafür sind die union sich schlecht
wie nie zuvor das wird glaube ich und
war ihr fest gesichert ein oder anderen
gegner bis zum letzten tag regiert der
ja das ist eine große leistung
tatsächlich friedrich merz hat das erst
mal gesagt sie ist die einzige die nicht
mit den füßen nach vorne aus dem aus der
hintertür getragen wurde das fand ich
sehr despektierlich in wahrheit hat sie
diese 16 jahre trotz also zumindest nach
öffentlicher aussagen ihrer eigenen
aussage selbstbestimmt beendet das ist
die längste regentschaft eines kanzlers
oder einer kanzlerin in diesem fall die
selbstbestimmt geendet hat mir wissen
helmut kohl hat verloren sie hat gesagt
musste sagen was auch immer auf jeden
fall hat sie gesagt ich scheide aus
damit das ist eine große leistung allein
dass ich da die geschichte wird sie
anders beschreiben als die niedergang
der cdu mit ihr fest zu machen er wird
möglicherweise mit jemandem anderen noch
einmal kurz zu dem punkt es geht in der
politik nicht darum dass ich mir einen
nachfolger aufbau der dann nach minsk
kommt sondern da ist wirklich sich jeder
selbst der nächste oder seinen bruch
verbinden verbündeten die gibt es auch
noch aber ein nachfolger aufzubauen der
dann ins amt volk gibt es vielleicht bei
george bush und
ronald reagan in umgekehrter reihenfolge
aber an sondern dass das nicht so
einfach also das glaube ich nicht dass
das so ist also dass
qualität das zu sagen dass das kein
politiker daran interesse hat dass wenn
man rausgeht dass es vernünftig weiter
geht also ich bin gerade in version aber
der sonst so dass ich die politik
verlassen und ich habe ein unglaublich
großes interesse daran dass den den
landesverband hamburg den ich wieder
aufgebaut habe und wo ich auch im
bundesverband mit unterstützt habe dass
das gut weitergehe werde ich daraus gehe
ich möchte doch nicht dass das was ich
mit der arbeit habe wo ich so viel
herzblut reingesteckt dass das jetzt wie
ein kartenhaus in sich zusammen deswegen
habe ich schon den letzten jahren immer
geguckt dass wir gute leute aufgebaut
haben dass wir talente gefunden haben
weil ich ja immer wussten irgendwann
kommt dieser abschied und dann dann
möchte ich nicht dass das das was ich
mein baby vor dem nichts steht also
hatte ich ein unglaublich großes
interesse und ich freue mich dass es
jetzt so gut weitergeht ich hab dann
unglaublichen spaß dann alles andere
fertig schrecklich wenn ich sehen müsste
dass ich da alles weggebombt hätte und
da jetzt nichts in dem nichts mehr nach
gewachsen wäre das ja nicht weitergehen
würde wäre schrecklich für das junge
paar mich nicht die einzige also das
wird er sagen dass du dich gerne um das
thema zu beenden zum nächsten zu kommen
nämlich zu dem wlan- würde ich gerne
alexander noch eine frage fragen zu dem
thema ist frau suding vielleicht nicht
die typische politikerin wenn sie das
gerade ja vorgetragen hat wie viele es
ja auch bedeutet also dass da hat sich
doch recht dass politiker auch denken an
die an die zeit danach es ist auch eine
verantwortung fürs staatswesen aber ich
glaube wenn jemand so wahlständen den
frau merkel abgrundtief schrecklich
finde also sagen wir mal die afg stunde
war 35 prozent dann würden wir sie hören
geben natürlich aber wir sehen noch da
sind drei kandidaten zur auswahl die
frau merkel findet alle ganz respektabel
findet und die glaubt dass ich glaube
frau merkel denkt nicht wenn die cdu
nicht regierte deutschland unter das
denkt sie einfach nicht und das denken
viele deutsche und man sie hat auch in
den letzten jahren wenn man ehrlich ist
eine gemäßigt sozialdemokratische
politik gemacht warum sollen sie dann
ganz schlimm finden wenn herr scholz das
weitermacht ich glaube so tickt sie
einfach nicht also wir halten fest wir
wissen nicht was frau merkel wählt
[Musik]